(sea lions barking)
- I kind of compare it with
being at a giant dog park.
Some of them love it.
Like you start giving
them arm pit scratches
and they're just like giant dogs.
They just start rolling around,
and they're flying all around you.
But these animals are huge.
People are intimidated by them,
but once you, once you
learn their behavior,
they're just right into you right away.
They just look at you like a big chew toy.
(soft peaceful music)
(motor running)
(uptempo piano music)
I could never see myself living anywhere
other than the Pacific Northwest.
(wind blowing)
I could literally spend every single day
of the rest of my life
and never travel anywhere
other than Vancouver Island
and it would still never have enough time
to see this whole place.
(water splashes)
My first introduction
to the ocean would have
definitely come from my mom.
That's me with a sea lion right there.
Later on in life,
I realized it is pretty unique experience
to get to help and spend
time with these animals
on a regular basis.
(sea lions barking)
Sea lions are a large intelligent animal
and they're very sensitive
of what your intentions are
and how they choose to interact with you
is totally their choice.
If you're comfortable
and their inquisitive
they'll come and they'll chew on you fins,
or come up and they chew
on the edge of your mask,
or give you, uh, big kisses on the lips,
or big hugs.
They wrap their fins around
you and give you a big hug.
People get sketched out about it.
(soft relaxing music)
Like I've had lots of people
contact me and be like,
"Don't you think those
things are aggressive?"
Just because an animal's
putting it's mouth
on you doesn't mean it's
doing it in a harmful way.
They don't have hands,
they can't explore their world
with anything other than their mouth.
There's people that
spend, now, a lot of money
to travel to the other side of the planet
to watch a group of
large migratory animals
in Africa or something, say,
and here I can just go out on my boat
and it's not something I take
for granted at all anymore,
having the opportunity to do this.
(relaxing music)